parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro des étudiants
d'une école d'ingénieurs les nintendo
août avant d'une voiture performante et
peu consommatrices de carburant une
somme allés à leur rencontre
les insectes et les ont toutes un
pouvoir naturel ce qui les rend
nécessaire à la biodiversité
mais il aurait aussi des pouvoirs
magiques un ouvrage nous les fait
découvrir le tour alternative a fait ce
qu'elle a mummy mais à mots pour parler
du changement climatique avant la coop
21 la région ile de france a présenté un
projet de contribution pour la com 21 la
conférence internationale sur les
changements climatiques qui débutera le
30 novembre prochain à paris le
président de la région jean paul huchon
a notamment annoncé la rénovation de
25000 logements en cinq ans un
investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables et l'aide à la rénovation
thermique
cette contribution propose aussi une
immersion dans le quotidien de neuf
familles type comme une famille d'actifs
bientôt retraités une famille
d'agriculteurs ou une famille aisée
parisienne je prends par exemple oublier
une famille d'agriculteurs cinéman qui a
les difficultés du monde agricole qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui comment elle va
pouvoir davantage contribuer à
l'alimentation de la région par exemple
par du maraîchage et très très peu de
maraîchage tour de l'agglomération
parisienne
bon et si elle fait ça et pique elle va
sur les marchés dans les amap etc
il va pouvoir faire de la vente directe
et avoir je dirais le revenu
je dirais en évitant des intermédiaires
qui va faire qu'on va pouvoir bien
vendre ses produits
toujours à propos de la coop 21 à la fin
du mois de septembre les centres de la
poste des hauts-de-seine et des yvelines
ont organisé un mais coralie dans le
cadre de la semaine de la mobilité
le but n'était pas d'être le plus rapide
mais de consommer le moins une
cinquantaine de salariés de partenaires
y ont participé
afin de s'engager dans la transition
énergétique un reportage signé fanny
bourdillon ils sont 27 équipages à
s'élancer de la plate forme industrielle
de bois d'arcy pour le premier rallye
d'éco-conduite de l'ouest francilien le
but ralliait la plateforme industrielle
de villeneuve la garenne en consommant
le moins possible de carburant et de
batteries une cause de 40 km organisée
par la poste afin de sensibiliser leurs
salariés à l'éco conduite à la conduite
économique en fait économiser un maximum
de carburant une conduite légère et
souple pas trop axé sur l'accélérateur
est passé vitesse entre 1500 et 2000
tours minute
tous les facteurs du département ont
reçu une formation à l'éco-conduite les
gestes clés ils sont enseignés pour
adopter une conduite plus économes
l'ensemble de nos salariés formés par
nos filiales mobigreen donc c'est une
formation sur site avec la mise en place
d'un simulateur qui est fait des rappels
à la fois sur le code de la route
l'environnement
auxquels ils peuvent être confrontés et
qui leur met en place des simulations de
consommation pour qu'ils puissent se
rendre compte comment on agit
concrètement sur la diminution de la
consommation que ce soit thermique ou
électrique une conduite douce qui
apporte de nombreux avantages
une diminution des coûts de carburant
une conduite plus apaisé mais surtout
une réduction de l'empreinte sur
l'environnement l'objectif de la poste
et de réduire de 15% leurs émissions de
co2 d'ici 2020
nous sommes à l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs qui a ouvert ses portes à
montigny le bretonneux au début du mois
de septembre les étudiants qui sont ici
ce sont eux qui imagineront nos voitures
de demain et ils ont déjà commencé c'est
la raison de notre présence
la voiture que vous voyez derrière moi
c'est la 1e c01 une monoplace destinée
une compétition internationale pour en
parler nous sommes avec gabriel mertens
bonjour bonjour vous êtes l'ancien
président de l'association estac à
formula team et vous êtes aussi un des
étudiants qui travaillent sur cette
voiture
pour commencer ce que vous pouvez me l'a
présenté alors cette première voiture
était entièrement conçu en 2011 puis
fabriqué en 2013 alors c'est un une
voiture de thé monoplace donc une seule
place pour le conducteur
alors celle ci pèse 100 94 kg et elle
est propulsée par un moteur de moto bmw
et comment fonctionne-t-elle alors lors
elle fonctionne à l'essence 98 comme
vous trouver partout à la pompe et au
début nous voulions faire une voiture
électrique
cependant les technologies est encore
très cher et la conception était aussi
très très compliqué c'est pour ça que
nous avons commencé non quand thermique
avec ce moteur essence et ensuite avec
l'expérience qu'on a acquis notre campus
qui se situe à laval a pu donc se lancer
en électrique si on en parle dans le
magazine équilibrer le magazine de
l'environnement il ya quand même une
raison même si elle fonctionne à
l'essence
je crois savoir que vous cherchez à
consommer le moins possible
alors tout à fait l'objectif le premier
objectif de cette voiture et la
performance
cependant aujourd'hui
et suivant les règlements de la
compétition la performance ne peut être
atteinte sans ignorer le facteur de la
consommation et des émissions de
polluants et c'est pourquoi cette
voiture une des principales lignes
directives de ce projet était le poids
allégé au maximum le véhicule or
aujourd'hui dans l'industrie automobile
c'est un des facteurs clé du progrès et
de l'écologie et nous travaillons
actuellement sur un nouveau projet pour
un nouveau véhicule encore plus léger
qui pourrait donc consommer environ 15 à
20% de carburant en moins par rapport à
la première
ça a été comme ans en 2011 vous le
disiez nous sommes en 2015 est-ce que
vous avez déjà on sait quatre années
réussi à réduire votre consommation
alors tout à fait nous allons travailler
sur le moteur lui-même que vous voyez
ici derrière donc grâce aux nombreux
réglages qu'on a fait donc sur des
bombes en rouleau sur le banc moteur
nous avons pu économiser jusqu'à 10% de
carburant grâce aux dépens de
l'optimisation de réglage en termes de
chiffres de consommation votre moteur
c'est quoi alors on tournait au ont
tourné autour des 7 litres aux cent
alors les estimations sont un peu vague
à cause d'eux des performances qui se
meuvent est très variable mais voilà
c'est le chiffre que nous avons un
objectif
cette voiture elle est construite dans
l'optique de la formula student une
compétition internationale où 2500
étudiants je crois ce s'affrontent
est ce que vous pouvez me donner le but
de cette compétition
alors cette compétition a pour but donc
de faire donc non seulement de fabriquer
des véhicules très performants mais
aussi de former des futurs ingénieurs au
métier donc
qui les attend puisque cette compétition
est vraiment fait pour les ingénieurs
parce qu'on ne juge pas donc la
performance du pilote est vraiment les
capacités de la voiture et c'est
pourquoi lors de ces épreuves nous avons
des épreuves statiques ou un jury formé
d'ingénieurs certains venant même de la
formule 1 est donc jugée mettre des
notes et discuter avec nous donc c'est
ce que nous avons réussi avec ce
véhicule est alors passée cette voiture
dans cette compétition ça a donné
quelque chose alors lors de la première
année nous avons remporté le prix de
best newcomer c'est-à-dire meilleure
nouvelle équipe
nous nous en étions très fiers sûr il y
avait 100 équipes dans le classement
nous avons fini 64e donc c'est un
événement marquant et en général votre
voiture elle se situe ou par rapport aux
autres concurrents vous consommez trop
vous consommez moins qu' on est très
bien placé parmi les compétiteurs
puisque nous faisons partie des voitures
les plus légères la moyenne de poids des
véhicules de cette compétition entre 210
et 220 kg comme je vous l'aï dit nous
sommes à 190 de plus nous avons des
moteurs les plus petits les plus légers
et donc un de ceux qui consomment le
moins
merci et brianne verte entre toutes ces
explications n'ont rien merci à vous
trois animaux sur quatre de la planète
sont des insectes et chaque année les
scientifiques on découvre de nouvelles
espèces
un insecte hologue vice-président de
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement qui est située à
guyancourt publie un ouvrage sur les
insectes volants mêlant réalité et
imaginaire toutes ces faits sont plus
belles les unes que les autres
les syrphes les bourdons les libellules
les insectes et les serait défait et l'
ouvrage les vrais fait de la nature va
vous le démontrer dans le cadre de mes
recherches j'ai me suis rendu compte que
les faits avaient une similitude très
forte avec les insectes
et dans toute l'économie raffy autour
des faits ces derniers de ces derniers
siècles
vous voyez des faits avec des ailes de
papillon dld libellules et c est ça m'a
semblé évident que les faits étaient des
insectes et que c'est les insectes qui
avait inspiré notre imaginaire autour
des faits 65 fait à découvrir en 144
pages mêlant le sérieux avec étymologie
petite histoire et pouvoir naturel et
l'imaginaire avec un pouvoir magique
alors par exemple je prends la fée lui
kahn qui est un gros coléoptère et bas
parmi les pouvoirs naturels qu'elle a
l'odeur des excréments projetée par la
femelle attire lehman ça c'est quelque
chose qu'elle fait vraiment dans la
nature
et puis dessous je précise un pouvoir
magique
l'attrapé sans se faire pincer ce
qu'elle a d'énormes mandibules qui
peuvent passer est signe que notre
chance est prolongée agrémenté des
photos de stéphane heyd spécialiste de
la photographie nature l'ouvragé vise
aussi à démystifier l'animal je trouve
qu'on a vraiment on manque de
bienveillance vis-à-vis des autres êtres
vivants des animaux non humains qui sont
autour de nous du coup je cherche des
idées tout le temps tout le temps pour
que chacun de nous qui intéresse
davantage et le côté imaginaire le côté
féerique de cette idée et je l'espère
une autre clé d'entrée pour plein de
gens
une clé d'entrée pour aller voir cette
nature entre l'afld et impératrices qui
efface les mauvaises pensées et la fée
mixte qui apporte un mélange de joie et
de plénitude
avec cet ouvrage vous ne regarderez plus
les insectes de la même manière
ils sont une centaine à avoir parcouru
ce 5000 km à vélo en france en belgique
mais aussi en allemagne
le collectif alternatiba s'est lancé ce
défi en juin dernier pour aller à la
rencontre des citoyens et par les
changements climatiques
ils ont fait étape le 22 septembre à
magny les hameaux un sujet préparé avec
camille lambert
la pluie ne les aura pas arrêter partie
du perray-en-yvelines dans la matinée
les vingt cyclistes du jour parcourt en
moyenne 60 km à vélo
déjà les tandems représente à la fois la
transition écologique puisque on
avec notre nos muscles et voilà
on pollue pas est à la fois l'effort
partagé la solidarité puisque on a
besoin d'être coordonnées on
ensemble on est on est lié quoi parti le
5 juin dernier deux bayonne le tour a
fait escale dans 187 commune pour
participer à des conférences et
rencontrer les citoyens avec un objectif
parler du changement climatique
nous on en parle avec eux parce que
jenson en sont conscients pour leur dire
en fait si c'est possible il ya plein
d'alternatives concrètes possibles dès
aujourd'hui sur tous les domaines de la
vie quotidienne que ce soit
l'alimentation l'énergie des transports
la récupération et ses derniers réglages
les équipes se reforme
ils reprennent la route direction
malakoff le 26 septembre ils doivent
être à paris pour le festival de la
capitale avant nous quitter noter ces
quelques rendez vous si vous voulez
découvrir les paysages agricoles
historiques ou moderne le magny les
hameaux sky en transition vous propose
une randonnée le dimanche 27 septembre
vous pourrez peut-être récolté fruits et
légumes jusqu'au 15 octobre la lex 50
ans giving organise le festival le
climat au microscope 21
au programme des conférences débats des
visites notamment celle d'une maison en
paille ou d'une usine de méthanisation
tous les renseignements sur le site
internet et les 10 et 11 octobre c'est
la fête de la science à guyancourt pour
l'occasion l'observatoire de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ouvre ses
portes avec des visites et des ateliers
au programme
voilà équilibre c'est terminé je vous
donne rendez vous le mois prochain et
d'ici là
pensez à faire un geste pour
l'environnement